Hey Youtubers it’s Charlie, I hope you guys
all got a chance to see The Flash.
I did a non-spoilery review this summer, so
this video will be top 10 moments and comic
book references.
Don’t forget that the first episode of Arrow
Season 3 is tomorrow too.
It will also be amazing.
I’ll be doing videos for all of the DC Comics
TV Shows this fall and probably doing a few
random giveaways so be sure to subscribe to
get everything.
Careful for spoilers from The Flash if you
haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Number 10 - John Wesley Shipp Is Barry’s
Father
This is one of the best callbacks to the old
Flash TV Show from the 90s.
Not to make any puns, but that didn’t “run”
for very long but John Wesley Shipp also left
a pretty big mark as the Barry Allen version
of the Flash.
Even his co-star, Amanda Pays has been cast
on the new Flash show.
She’s playing the same character as she
did in the classic series.
Doctor Tina McGee of STAR Labs.
It’s just really awesome of the producers
to include the classic cast in a big way.
John Wesley Shipp will mostly be stuck in
Iron Heights, but he does have a recurring
role.
So we will see him a couple more times this
season.
I don’t know if they’re going to give
him any action scenes, but he’s in Iron
Heights Prison, where they stick all the super
criminals they capture.
So he might get to punch someone in the face
at some point.
Number 9 - Professor Zoom Tease At The Top
of the Episode
Right away they come out and say yes, here
is the biggest villain The Flash has ever
had.
Just for reference, during the TCAs, Greg
Berlanti and Andrew Kriesberg said that the
Reverse Flash here would start to manifest
himself early in the season, so expect to
see more Professor Zoom after the first couple
of episodes.
I’d say at least by episode 5 or 6.
In time to set something up for the Mid-Season
finale.
Yes, I do think that Professor Zoom will appear
in the mid-season finale.
Even though the title of that is Arrow versus
Flash and the second half is called The Brave
and the Bold.
I feel like mid-season finale’s are bookmarked
for Big Villain reveals
Number 8 - The CSI Procedural Structure to
the Show
The Flash is an origin story for a whole lot
of comic book characters, so it naturally
lends itself to the process of discovery.
By doing a superhero CSI type show, you can
get into all the really cool science of super
powers.
And The Flash will be doing Superpowers.
STAR Labs is The Flash’s Version of the
Arrow Cave, and it’s a cutting edge research
facility.
I don’t think they’ll get too hardcore
with exposition, this is the CW after all.
It’s more about the characters than the
powers.
But the big tease is the map here on the screen.
All these pockets of energy will be creating
new super villains and super heroes.
I’ll talk more about them as they show up
in episodes.
The next big one is episode 3.
Number 7 - Barry’s Mystery Board
This is one of the big plots for season 1,
solving the mystery of what really happened
the night his mother was murdered.
During that same TCAs panel I mentioned, the
producers said they would stay really faithful
to the general arc of Flash Rebirth.
That’s the comic that Geoff Johns used to
bring Barry Allen back from the dead.
You should definitely read it, it’s really
good.
The Murder Mystery gets tied up with the big
villain arc in this really nice way.
So
Because a lot of people haven’t read that
comic book please use spoiler tags when talking
about the plot.
Number 6 - The Gorilla Grodd Teaser
There hasn’t been any confirmation that
Grodd is going to be in season 1.
Greg Berlanti said he actually had to argue
with the network to keep the easter egg in
there.
But they are planning things so they can do
Grodd eventually.
Nothing is off the table in terms of Flash
characters.
They even said that they’d be doing Wally
West at some point.
Not This season, but you get the idea.
The Grodd thing isn’t a teaser for this
season, it was intended more as a wink to
the fans.
But it will probably turn into something in
a future season.
Number 5 - Ferris Air
I know everyone wants to know when Green Lantern
is coming on but if they did bring him into
the tv show universe, it would be through
Arrow first.
It’s really the test bed for things that
big.
But yes, they have said they’re open to
Hal Jordan someday.
There’s not really room for him this season,
but there’s nothing saying they couldn’t
let him cameo in a future season.
Or even Carol Ferris for that matter.
Star Sapphire’s for the win!
Number 5 - Caitlin Snow’s Career and her
Fiance were killed in the blast
Caitlin Snow is Killer Frost in the comics,
so it’s possible on the show danielle could
have powers and just not be telling them about
it.
Her Fiancee that supposedly died is Ronnie
Raymond aka Firestorm.
He’s being played by Robbie Amell on the
show.
We’ll meet him for the first time in Episode
3 or 4 I believe.
But he will become Firestorm.
Robbie Amell has been tweeting pictures from
the set and it looks pretty cool.
Number 4 - Clyde Mardon becomes the first
of the Rogues
Weather Wizard is just the first of many Rogues
that will be on the series.
They even posted the first official picture
of Wentworth Miller as Captain Cold.
I’m hoping that by the end of the season
they actually team up and call themselves
The Rogues.
For those wondering, at the end of the episode
he’s being transferred to Iron Heights.
Eventually that’s going to turn into their
Arkham Asylum.
Feel free to make any Prison Break jokes you
want.
Because there are a lot of Prison Break actors
playing Rogues.
Number 3 - Detective Pretty Boy
They named him Edward Thawne, which is a play
on Eobard Thawne, Professor Zoom.
It’s pretty clear he’s normal in the episode.
But it’s possible that they named him like
Professor Zoom, but they’ll give him the
storyline from Hunter Zolomon in the comics.
Hunter Zolomon works at the police station
and shares some of the exhibited qualities
of Rick Cosnett in this episode.
There are a lot of directions they could go
with his character.
But he did not attend any of the press tour
events.
Probably because he’s going to get tied
up in the big villain arc this season.
Number 2 - The Stephen Amell Cameo
This is a good teaser for the shared universe
that Arrow and the Flash will have this season.
Actors will only cross over to each show a
few times, the mid season finale of both shows
will be a two hour crossover event.
Felicity will be the next person to crossover
in the fourth episode I think.
Number 1 - The Newspaper
The Harrison Well future newspaper thing could
mean a lot.
He could be Professor Zoom, he could be a
future version of Barry Allen, or he could
be one of the other reverse flashes.
The big easter egg was the Queen Industries,
Wayne Tech merger.
That’s not intended to be anything special.
It’s just like the gorilla grodd thing.
They just wanted to have some fun with the
fandom.
They’re not teasing an infinite crisis storyline
or anything either.
But Harrison Wells is someone we need to keep
our eyes on.
Let me know what your favorite moment was,
it’s going to be an amazing season.
I will do as many bonus videos as possible
for both Arrow and The Flash, Arrow is tomorrow
and thursday I’ll do a shared Q&A for both
shows.
For those asking, you don’t absolutely have
to watch both Arrow and the Flash to understand
the other show, but it will make it a lot
more fun if you do.
So you should.
Right now click here for my Flash Review and
click here to start getting ready for Arrow
Season 3.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
I’ll see you tonight!